am Mittwoch als die Umweltverbände
schäumten wegen der Beschlüsse abends
zuvor hatte er eine beruhigende
Botschaft dabei niemand brauche sich
Sorgen wegen eines schnellen teuren
heizungstauschs und werde flexible
Lösungen anbieten man werde niemanden
zurücklassen und deshalb kann ich auch
ihnen Sie bitten dass sie alle
Bürgerinnen und Bürger die ihnen
schreiben beruhigend sagen alles gut der
Kanzler macht das ordentlich und das
wird auch funktionieren alle wieder
hinlegen so klang das Klimaschutz schon
und gut aber überfordern dürfe der
niemanden er bekam viel Applaus dafür
aus jener Partei die ihn vor anderthalb
Jahren noch so plakatierte als Klima
Kanzler in speech damit voll im Trend
der Druck der Straße machte fast alle
Parteien zu klimafreunden auch bei der
Union ein zweiter Anlauf nachdem sie nie
die Klimakanzlerin wurde die sie vorgab
zu sein entdeckte man das narrativ vom
Erhalt der Schöpfung manche mehr manche
weniger hemmungslos
[Musik]
für das Original die Grünen öffnete sich
ein historisches Fenster das Kanzleramt
Schienen Reichweite die Frage weniger ob
er wann doch dieses historische Fenster
scheint sich jetzt genauso schnell
wieder zu schließen denn nun da eine
nach grünem Gusto reglementierte
Republik auch nur in Konturen erkennbar
wird und damit ihr Preisschild sagt die
Mehrheit danke aber danke nein
Hinweise aus jüngster Zeit der
Volksentscheid in Berlin erfolglos
Verbrenner aus Mehrheit dagegen deutlich
verschärfte Auflagen bei Heizungen
ebenso
schnellere Autobahnausbau Mehrheit dafür
klare Zahlen und schon erkalte die neue
Leidenschaft fürs Klima wenn man sieht
wie vor kurzem noch manche Parteien auch
außerhalb der Wahlkämpfe dafür
geschwärmt haben nun klimapolitische
Ziele durchzusetzen ob das nun in
Süddeutschland oder in Berlin gewesen
ist kann man heute feststellen die
Begeisterung dafür war nur vorgetäuscht
es war der Versuch weder zu gewinnen
aber es war nicht der Versuch
tatsächlich eine Änderung der
politischen Charaktere dieser Parteien
zu erreichen für die Grünen ist Alter
das ein Desaster es droht wieder die
Nische doch da sind sie nun auch nicht
mehr willkommen denn während sie für die
Masse zu viel wollen wollen sie für ihre
Basis zu wenig der Versuch sich aus
diesem Dilemma offensiv rauszudribbeln
bleibt ein Versuch es ist nicht viel
mehr so dass man vielleicht sogar fast
stolz darauf sein kann dass wir die
Kraft haben eine Regierung wieder mit
zum Arbeiten zu bringen was bringt es
einem wenn man eine Ampel am Laufen hält
die konsequent rot zeigt für den
Klimaschutz man hört das
Klimaschutzgesetz was von der
schwarz-roten Regierung kommt was das
Bundesverfassungsgericht in Teilen als
verfassungswidrig eingestuft hat man
hört das noch weiter aus und macht damit
elementare Fortschritte die auch in den
vergangenen Jahren im Klimaschutz
erreicht wurden tatsächlich zu Nichte
und das als Fortschritt zu bezeichnen
ist es einfach absolut so wächst der
Frust bei den Grünen zumal auch eine
prinzipielle Schubumkehr in der
Koalition nicht mehr zu übersehen ist
aus rot grün gegen gelb wurde rot gelb
gegen Grün vor allem über den Kanzler
fallen hinter den Kulissen der Grünen
sehr rustikale Worte diese Woche vor der
Kamera klingt es so in der Tat es ist
ernüchtern zu sehen dass trotz der
Dramatik und das zwingend notwendigen
Handelns und der Tatsache dass manche
Sektoren kein Beitrag leisten bisher die
Ambitionen Klimaschutz voranzubringen
sich doch auf uns Grüne konzentriert an
den Partnern hört die Kritik ab man
fühlt sich wohl im neuen Pragmatismus
und will daran wohl auch nicht mehr
rütteln formuliert in einer sehr
vornehmen Variante von friss oder stirb
die SPD ist in keiner Sekunde gegen
ambitionierten Klimaschutz aber wir
wissen eben ambitionierter Klimaschutz
über 2025 Jahre braucht
gesellschaftlichen Rückhalt und wenn wir
ihnen Praxis und realitätsfern
vorantreiben dann werden wir die Leute
gegen uns haben und dann gibt es am Ende
gar kein Klimaschutz diesem Eindruck und
dem Mangel der Handlungsfähigkeit wollte
die Ampel dann offenbar schnell noch
etwas entgegensetzen Freitagabend wird
plötzlich ein geeinter Gesetzentwurf zum
heizungsdurch verkündet doch es folgt
gleich der nächste Kampf um die
Deutungshoheit ihre beiden Ministerien
verschicken per Mail unterschiedliche
Interpretationen großer Wurf für den
Klimaschutz so die Botschaft von habex
Haus kein neuer Zwang und
technologieoffenheit betont Lindners
Ministerium eine Regierung zwei
Richtungen und ein Kanzler bei dem laut
Politbarometer nur noch 26% der
Befragten Führungsstärke erkennen nichts
Konkretes steht übrigens auch im neuen
Entwurf zu den versprochen en
finanziellen Hilfen hier muss nun vor
allem die SPD liefern federführend
beteiligt neben dem Kanzler
bauministerin klargewitz